you know what pisses me off is you've
played lex luthor longer than any other
lex luthor including me
do you know that that's an accident but
no no no you
you played him more consistently i'll
bet you actually have more hours of
playing like sweetheart
i mean if we actually added up the time
what about crier how many episodes did
he do
crier i think's only he's in the second
season oh so he's way behind he's got
he's got time
you win you we we all know who who likes
luther
no no no no people really i'm telling
you you have a
following man you have a following and
people love you
but it doesn't matter i've said that
before and people are insulted when i
say well it's saying i'm you know
well it's animation when i do this no no
that role
means in as much as live action to
most people many people i understand
that i understand that
because i understand that because that's
sort of the
world that that superman was created
right
but but the live-action adaptations
they're hard to do and smallville was
the best of them
oh come on yeah no no smallville was
definitely the best of them
uh you know lois and clark was kind of
fun for
for a minute you know because everybody
was young and good looking
but it you know it became a soap opera
and nobody really cared after a while
but smallville
smallville was like the right show at
the right time
really realized real well i i think
smallville's just kind of
genius i didn't even know you watched it
yeah i saw a couple episodes sure
well really i'm not really the demo for
it but you know
you're not that much older than i am how
old are you i'm old i'm 61
60. what is the 20 yeah 20. 20 i'm 61.
that's not old